bonsoir mesdames et messieurs au moment
où des milliards de dollars vont être
dépensés pour remplacer le pont
champlain
notre équipe d' enquête a découvert une
histoire de présumés pots-de-vin
impliquant michel fourni il était pdg de
la société des ponts fédéraux d'une
histoire qui implique également la firme
snc lavalin cela remonte un chantier sur
le pont jacques cartier c'était en 2002
voici ce qu'a obtenu and panassac
rappelez vous la réfection du pont
jacques cartier
de 2000 à 2002 la société des ponts
fédéraux entrepris de refaire tout le
tablier du pont de nuit pour ne pas
perturber la circulation
un contrat de 127 millions de dollars
effectué par un consortium dirigé par
snc lavalin or à la même époque michel
fournier le pdg de la société des ponts
et ancien proche collaborateur de jean
chrétien ouvre un compte en suisse
promo tag une agence régulièrement
engagé par snc lavalin dépose des sommes
importantes dans ce compte
cette fois en 2002 deux fois en 2003 et
deux autres en 2004 pour un total de
près de 2 millions et demi de dollars
depuis michel fournier a pris sa
retraite nous l'avons retrouvé ici à
victoria en colombie britannique
j'ai jamais reçu painchaud de la part de
snc lavalin de promote accès aux quelque
chose l'agent commercial il est utilisé
par snc lavalin pour tour de dos il
s'appelle promoteurs n'ont jamais reçu
le projet la justice suisse pointe elles
ont posé des questions aux gens des
synthés naval 1 sur 1 4 million $ qui a
été versée à votre compte écoutez j'ai
jamais reçu de sans doute snc lavalin
michel fournier nie aussi avoir ouvert
un compte en suisse donc je me lève en
2000 n'ont jamais ouvert de compte entre
votre votre passeport a été donné en
garantie on a vu des photos ses fournit
j'ai vu les photos écouter d'après ce
que je vois ici il n'y a pas de doute là
de la personne a été identifiée
physiquement dans les lois suisses donc
on peut pas juste par procuration ouvrir
un compte à quelqu'un qui est ailleurs
il faut absolument qu'il soit présent
qu'on constate son identité vu qu'on le
fasse signe michel fournier nous a
rappelés pour admettre au téléphone
qu'il avait ouvert ses comptes en suisse
mais comme prête-nom pour sa belle soeur
aujourd'hui décédé qui voulait cacher de
l'argent à son conjoint la belle femme a
demandé
le cri
il n'a toujours aucune explication quant
au paiement de promo tag snc lavalin a
répondu par courriel qu'elle n'avait
aucune information à partager avec nous
quant à l'actuel directeur des ponts
jacques cartier et champlain incorporée
jon corzine il a refusé de nous
rencontrer
anne
avec nous a d'abord première question ce
cas une enquête criminelle là dessus au
canada oui parce que ces informations-là
émane d'une enquête qui est en suisse et
qui était menée sur iad benaïssa vous
vous souvenez la sélection et reed snc
lavalin qui est emprisonné actuellement
aux suisses pour des allégations de
pots-de-vin payés à des ex dictateur a
raison ils ont ils sont tombés là dessus
mais finalement ça les intéresse pas
vraiment ce que je comprends c'est
qu'ils ont transféré toutes les
informations ici au canada la grc qui a
ouvert une enquête et puis ce n'est pas
il faut dire le premier cas qu'implique
snc-lavalin et canada bien sûr il ya la
libye l'algérie au canada où il reçut je
les cuisine le centre universitaire de
santé de mcgill vos vraie plaie il ya
des accusations qui ont été portées
contre l'ex pdg de snc lavalin pierre
duhaime de fraude et contre l'ancien
directeur de l'hôpital pour 22 points 5
millions de dollars de pots-de-vin tout
ça alors fait le procès va avoir lieu en
2015 la suite ce soir votre reportage
plus long enquête merci beaucoup merci
au revoir